okay so you know how they always do
like a before and after of the presidents at
like at the beginning of their term and at the end
because they've always aged a lot and like
look so different because the job is just worn them down
I feel like I need to make sure to be doing a before and after of me
for the next four years of this administration
because we it hasn't even started
and I've aged significantly in the last week
this headline alone has aged me
this is what you guys are gonna see in four years
I'm gonna be like they used to do press conferences at the White House
and not just with Fox News
they would do them with all of the different news channels
even the ones that were a bit hard on them
used to have federal agencies
there used to be a department of education
you used to not be able to profit off the presidency
you know Jimmy Carter even sold his peanut farm anyways
I hate it here it's been the longest week of my life